this world wasn't always so small and
petty
thousands of years ago while the rest of
men prayed to gods
the valyrians became them
through magic or sheer will
they mastered the greatest creatures in
history
a horse grants man dominion over the
land a ship over the sea
but dragons
gave us the sky
and everything and everyone beneath it
at its height my ancestors ruled the
known world
whatever parts we didn't weren't worth
knowing
our capital of valyria shamed the
magnificent cities of the east for
hammers and chisels were no match for
dragon fire and sorcery
it was a city and an empire built to
last until the end of time
it didn't
400 years ago the doom fell on valyria
mountains cracked open like eggs lakes
and rivers boiled fountains of fire ash
and smoke spewed from the ground so high
and so hot that even dragons burned in
flight
the land splintered and the angry sea
rushed in
in hours
the greatest city in history
became history
but my ancestors didn't burn or drown
with the rest of their race
twelve years before the doom
despite the sneers of his rivals
aynar targaryen abandoned the capital
with his family
legends claimed that his daughter
foresaw the destruction of the city in a
dream
more likely aina met with some mishap at
court and chose exile over execution
he and house targaryen slinked away to a
dreary remote god forsaken island
forsaken
no longer
with arts now lost to the world
we transformed a tiny outpost into
dragonstone a fortress fit for the last
dragonlords
then ainar's descendants settled into it
like a tomb for their lost homeland
until aegon when he looked east
he saw the past
old tired
dead
but when he looked west
he saw the future
gold in the ground
gold in the fields and no dragons in the
sky but his
westeros has mighty rivers but none of
them compare to the roy it is said that
there is no stream or puddle in western
esses but drains to mother roy
no doubt an exaggeration
until one sees the river at its widest a
man in the center can't see ashore to
either side the greatest of mother roy's
children were the ruiner a civilization
as ancient and grand as old geese
fishers traders scholars workers of wood
stone and metal the ruiner raised their
elegant cities from the headwaters of
the royne down to her mouth each
lovelier than the last for many
centuries the rhino lived in relative
peace when invaders swept down from the
hills the ruiner women and men would don
silver-scaled armor fish head helms tall
spears and turtle shell shields if the
enemy did not laugh themselves away it
was said that mother royne would whisper
the enemy's secrets to her children and
the rhoynish wizards could raise watery
walls to drown their foes
whatever magic the ruiner may have had
it wasn't enough when valyrian colonists
first arrived the ruiner embraced them
for all men were welcome to share the
bounty of mother roy
perhaps a water people should have been
more cautious of strangers who exalted
fire and blood
legend has it that one day the valyrians
netted and butchered one of the giant
turtles the ruiner held sacred as a
result thousands were killed or enslaved
cities and towns were burned drowned and
rebuilt in these wars the valerians
emerged as victorious more often than
not the princes of the roiney cities
fiercely proud of their independence
fought alone whilst the valyrian
colonies aided one another
eventually the rhoynish princess ceased
their squabbling and united behind
prince garan who led the largest army
essas had ever seen against a hundred
thousand valyrian colonists a hundred
war elephants and three dragon lords
thousands burned but thousands more
sheltered in the shallows of the river
whilst the rhoynish wizards raised
enormous water spouts against the foes
dragons
rhoynish archers brought down two of the
dragons whilst the third fled wounded
and thereafter the ruiner named garen
the great
but mother valyria proved just as caring
as mother roy when garen the great
marched his army against philantis 300
valyrian dragons descended from the sky
tens of thousands burned whilst others
rushed into the river but the fires
burned so hot that the water boiled and
turned to steam
garen the great was captured alive and
made to watch as valyrians butchered
every last man so many that their blood
turned the great harbour of volantis red
as far as the eye could see
then they forced garen to watch as they
marched on his own city and enslaved all
the women and children his army had left
behind the singers claimed that prince
garan called out mother roin to curse
the valyrians and she in turn flooded
the city with foul waters and a damp fog
that caused the skin of the valyrians to
harden and crack and thus was born
greyscale
fearing a similar fate another rhoynish
ruler princess namiria led her own
people into every ship skiff and raft
they had and fled essos eventually after
much hardship they landed in sun-swept
and bone-dry dawn
but we all know that tale
now valyria has followed the ruiner out
of this world and her daughters have
grown into free cities wealthy and
powerful and proud still mother ruined
flows on past ancient ruins and bustling
harbours sweeping all man's kingdoms to
the sea
according to legend house targaryen
survived the doom of valyria thanks to
danis the dreamer who foresaw the
calamity and convinced her father to
flee their homeland
it could be true
the targaryens were always a bit
more
but as mr yendle points out in the east
the targaryens were one of a thousand
minor noble families and in westeros
they became kings
politics not prophecy could have drawn
them to our shores
east of westeros lies the smoking sea
where no ship dares sail
there are those who swear it to be demon
haunted and who's to say they're wrong
for it was there
thousands of years ago that a
cataclysmic event occurred destroying
one of the great civilizations in
history
the precise details of their origins are
lost to us
but it is said the valyrians were once a
modest community of shepherds tending
their flocks on a small peninsula of the
great eastern continent
one fateful day in a volcanic area known
as the fourteen fires
they made a shattering discovery
dragons
they were monstrous scaled creatures
with massive wings sharp claws and fiery
breath
they were also said to have a
deep-rooted connection to magic
in time the valyrians were able to tame
the beasts
harnessing their immense power they
established a city of wonder unlike any
before or since
they became skilled at sorcery and
metallurgy
creating uncommon weapons of
spell-forged steel
wielding these weapons astride their
dragons the valyrians conquered the
surrounding lands and slowly expanded
west
at the time the ghiscari empire
dominated much of the great eastern
continent and tried to stop valyria's
expansion
the ghiscari legions attacked the
valyrians five times but could never
defeat them
finally the valyrians marched on their
capital old kiss
and obliterated it
turning its streets and buildings to ash
with dragonflame
and wiping the ghiscari people and their
culture off the face of the earth
the freehold of valyria as it came to be
known became the most advanced
civilization in the known world with its
own language gods and culture
the valyrians reach extended far and
wide covering most of the continent
great cities were built and roadways
paved all of which led back to valyria
the freehold would prosper for nearly
five thousand years
but it was not to last
an event that became known only as the
doom laid waste to the valyrians their
capital city and its surrounding lands
the peninsula itself was shattered
becoming what is now the smoking sea
every dragon was thought to be lost as
were the valyrian spells knowledge and
recorded history
thus the mighty empire collapsed
what caused this cataclysm
no one knows for certain
some say it was a volcanic eruption
others say the valyrian's own sorcery
got the better of them
in any event the doom's devastation of
the valyrian people was total
with the exception of a small rocky
island in the narrow sea
dragonstone
for it was there that the targaryens the
last of old valyria dwelled
they would line weight for another 100
years before unleashing the fury of the
dragon on another continent
westeros
you